well in just a matter of hours mask
wearing back for
everyone indoors this estate leaders try
to get a grip on the rising cobit case
numbers
amid the new delta variant good
afternoon to you on this thursday thanks
for staying with us at 4 30 i'm brian
loftis
and i'm christian cassette as we begin
with hector mejia near spring mountain
and valley view
with a look at how local businesses are
adjusting to the change
[Music]
well hey they're all businesses like
this one paris baguette they're
left to implement the new requirements
starting at midnight and this is what it
means for you as a customer
next time you come indoors you'll have
to wear a face mask and it doesn't
matter if you got the coronavirus
vaccine
this falls in line with the updated cdc
guideline from tuesday
saying put your mask back on and in
public
indoors if you are in an area with a
high transmission rate
clark county is listed as having one
according to the cdc vaccinated people
could spread the delta variant
more easily than previous versions of
covid19
nevada's new policy will override clark
county's mandate from just two weeks ago
which only requires employees to wear a
mask
the nevada restaurant association told
me today while they are waiting to
receive additional enforcement guidance
from osha
restaurants are following through so
places like paris baguette they're just
hoping customers are aware
ahead of time i think that if we respect
each other and we want to protect
each other we must wear masks
and we're going to ask respectfully if
they do not wear it
we haven't had any issues yet hopefully
we won't all right so the mandate goes
into effect
at midnight it also applies to resorts
and casinos earlier this week the nevada
gaming control board issued the same
guidance and also saying
that they must put up signage here at
this place there are no strangers to
face masks employees kept wearing one
even when it wasn't required reporting
near valley view and spring mountain
hector mejia
8 news now